okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to tonight's planning
committee meeting my name is Peter
Richards and I will be chairing the
meeting this evening and so housekeeping
start with if I may we're not expecting
a fire alarm so if one does go off Don't
Panic follow us over to the car park
Council car park over the road we will
need to check your names off on the
entry list uh just to make sure you've
got out the building safety so please
make sure you do that before you head
home
um mobile phones if you could please
turn them off at the very least of
Silence I appreciate sometimes they're
in emergencies so if you need to have
them on by all means do but make sure
they're on silent and they don't disturb
the flow of the meeting the meeting
itself is a meeting in public it is not
a public meeting so any of the people
who have registered to speak will be
permitted to do so at the appropriate
time I'll call you forward to one of the
four microphones in front of us here if
you press the button on the right the
microphone will be active you'll see a
little red light here and on the actual
machine as well and of course if you can
turn off again when you're not speaking
that would be greatly appreciated
um some intros uh if I may start with on
my far right we have Kira Keller who is
our Community Services representative to
my immediate right we have Sue Mullins
who is our solicitor our planners in no
particular order are Sarah Flaherty Amy
flute Sarah Leach and Victoria Kempton
and to my immediate left we have our
planning manager who is Richard Gardner
Richard I believe you've got a statement
to make please
uh yes thank you Mr chairman just to
confirm that my role tonight is to
provide impartial advice and to assist
members in their decision taking thank
you
marvelous thank you we are of course
being a recorded and live streamed as we
speak so please bear that in mind when
you are sitting and speaking let's dive
into the meeting itself um apologies do
we have any apologies please Kira yes we
have apologies from councilors Mills and
Pari were counselor Jennings as a
substitute marvelous welcome back
councilor Jennings uh disclosures of
Interest please members any disclosures
no okay let's move on from that um we
have some minutes so minutes of our
meeting on the 8th of March is everyone
happy with those
there's lots of nods and hands up yeah
all good we'll move on I'll sign those
after the meeting so let's go to our
first application which is application
reference
2202351 ful there's one acre in Barton
Road in Welford and I'll presenting
officer Sarah over to you
thank you chairman
the application site is within the built
up area boundary of worldford on Avon
and comprises land associated with the
existing dwelling at one acre as well as
Garden land to the rear of Stonecroft
hazelmere and three chimneys the site is
accessed via an existing access from
Barton Road and is bounded to the east
and south by residential development
this is a full planning application for
the demolition of the existing dwelling
known as one acre and the erection of
nine dwellings
a landscape buffer is proposed along the
north and west boundaries of the site
off street parking is provided to the
front of each of the proposed dwellings
the elevations can be seen on this Slide
the dwellings are a mixture of two three
and four bed units with two Dormer
Bungalows at the entrance to the site
and seven two-story detached dwellings
all plots would benefit from garages and
the dwellings would vary in height from
6.9 to 8.5 meters
this image shows the site as viewed for
Barton Road from the existing access
this image is taken facing north the
existing dwelling to be demolished can
be seen behind the tree on the right
this photo is taken facing into the site
and looking towards the northwest
this photo is taken facing back towards
Barton Road with the existing dwelling
one acre seen on the left and the
dwelling known as Stonecroft seen on the
right
this image is taken facing out of the
site in the direction of the public
footpath and the River Haven
and this final image is taken facing
towards the southeast and the dwellings
on headland Road can be seen in the
background
chairman the principal of development is
acceptable as is the design impact on
neighboring immunity flooding and impact
on highway safety
the recommendation is therefore to Grant
Subject to a legal agreement for
off-site affordable housing provision
and biodiversity offsetting and the
conditions as detailed on pages 24-26 of
the agenda and the updates in the update
sheet thank you
Sarah thank you very much indeed let's
call our first Speaker of the evening
who is councilor Neil Appleton of
Wellford Parish Council good evening
Council Appleton
now make yourself comfortable whenever
you are ready to go um obviously press
the button on the right and you'll have
three minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up otherwise
when you're set the floor is yours
welfare Parish Council are pragmatic and
I recognizer to oppose a principle of
development on this site will fail
historically this committee has not been
sympathetic to objections based on
housing limits set in cs-16
the parish council therefore submit that
the society is suitable for development
but the proposal is utterly inadequate
our aim is to secure the best outcome
for existing and future residents of the
village
the developer approached the parish
before submission to District we
indicated then that density was too high
and the housing mix did not meet policy
we also indicated that additional
footpath infrastructure was needed all
of this was ignored none are in this
proposal in short their consultation was
a whitewash they failed to meet the plan
making requirements of the mppf
the case officer points out the
development is small the parish council
agree the benefit to the district is is
as insignificant as the impact on roads
drainage and schooling the only
difference is that roads in Welford are
already crumbling the drainage failing
and the school full
the case officer cites policy in
concluding the housing mix is acceptable
however the most recent document on
housing mix the housing needs survey
from 2019 appears to have been ignored
no way is attached to it at all it is
not even listed as material evidence
the parish council feel that this may
constitute a breach of procedure
if the survey is properly considered the
proposal fails an appeal at Western
house was dismissed for this only last
year the house types proposed here are
similar hence the application does not
comply with housing needs and therefore
is contrary to policy CS6 cs19 and our
policy hlu4
in accordance with cs18 the development
of nine homes must include some
affordable housing there is none here
instead section 106 compensation is to
be secured this is simply not good
enough Welford is badly in need of
affordable homes and this site is a
prime candidate
housing density
by failing to provide a good standard of
space and Immunity for occupiers
occupies the development does not meet
the requirements of cs9 previous
proposals for up to nine dwellings have
been rejected
within a stone's throw along the bottom
note is another recent Village Edge
development occupying occupying just
over half the the area of one acre three
homes were approved and built here in
addition the garden boundaries of five
properties on headland Road adjoin the
site this gives an accurate sense of
existing density in this part of the
village
these five properties will suffer with
some degree loss of immunity
this contravenes two of welfare's
policies hlu2 and 5. using density and
changing layout this could be fixed 30
seconds but the developer has been
stubborn and clung to a design of nine
so resident amenity for families who
live close to here and are lucky enough
to get their children into the school
around the corner we'll have to cross a
road four times to get there on foot a
distance of less than half a mile the
parish council suggested two options one
was a direct footpath to the school
playing field a distance of no more than
100 meters the other was a new roadside
pavement these were both rejected
counter-ups and that is your three
minutes I'm afraid I'm gonna have to ask
you to make one final statement before
we close of course this proposal should
be rejected it fails to fulfill the
requirements of cs918 and 19 and Parish
policies hlu two four and five the
parish is receptive to a reasonable
proposal on this site but the developer
by failing to listen has not achieved
this
thank you very much indeed I have I've
obviously given you at eight seconds as
it happens eight and a half seconds over
so I do need to offer that to the other
speakers as well to be fair
um members do we have any questions for
our counselor please
cancer Curtis
thank you
um thank you very much
um you mentioned that the parish council
has put forward proposals regarding the
housing mix
um to the developers could you give a
little bit more information about what
housing mix would be acceptable to the
parish council
of course this is derived from our
housing needs survey um
if I could maybe reference actually
Weston house because this went to appeal
which was dismissed and you may recall
it came to committee uh in January upon
where a quantity was it was accepted
what they did what they had there was a
mix of there was four houses of three
four and five bedroom houses that was
rejected by the appeal inspector what
they did was to replace a couple of
those with two two bedroom Bungalows so
what you can see there is the the two
two bed Bungalows are being introduced
into the design now we don't have any
Bungalows here there's no single level
living in any of these in any of these
um buildings they're all to to story
um and the whole point of our housing
these survey is that
the building should be suitable for our
elderly residents so that they can stay
in the village
thank you Council Crump please
okay thank you sorry about that thank
you Mr chairman uh you you were
mentioning about the footpaths
um before you enter your time and about
Road Safety can you just tell me a
little bit more about that please
of course
um the is it possible to actually bring
up the very first Site Area um I can
sort of illustrate there so you can see
that the site is north of Barton Road
and the school is actually further north
and to access it you have to come out
onto Barton Road walk along and then you
go back up Headland Road you see now
that's not a very long distance it's
just as I say it's less than half a mile
at the moment the pavement on Barton
Road is on the south side of the road so
people walking to school would have to
cross over Barton Road and have to walk
up to Headland Road cross back over
Barton Road they'd have to cross over
Headland Road
um
from one pavement to another so in in
total you're talking about four Road
Crossings now it so happens that the
plot of land north of this is um
allotment
um I I'm sure that if the allotment can
be see were approached a footpath could
be just put along the edge of the
boundary and there'd be no
um
there'd be no roadside pavement needed
at all
um an alternative though was to put a
northern roadside pavement along Barton
Road to reduce the number of Road
Crossings
that was our proposal
any other questions counselor Harvey
please
thank you chairman
um
you mentioned that this was in your view
a site which was
um
appropriate for development on the basis
of affordable housing
my question to you is could you paint us
a picture could you find could you
provide information on the current state
of provision of affordable housing
within the locality I'm trying to get a
sense of how important the need for the
additional need for for or affordable
housing is in your area
okay so um
we have affordable housing in I think
three areas within Welford and there is
one a little bit further along the road
from here in Hollow Meadow
it is a small development on the edge of
the village it's been it's quite mature
it's been there for a little while and
we have also
um a small number of houses on Boston
Meadow
development which is again on the Barton
Road actually a bit further up because I
think there are about four or five
houses there and you may be aware that
kelstein has been
um approved recently I believe there's
some affordable housing I'm afraid I
don't actually have numbers on that in
front of me to my to mine so yes we do
have some affordable housing at the
moment but as you as you know Wellford
has taken quite a lot of affordable a
lot of new development but very little
of it has been affordable homes because
the nature of the development within
Welford is generally one or two
um
dwellings at a time and so they don't
attract the same
pressure to produce affordable housing
in that in that regard
okay do we have any other questions for
our Parish Council please
nope Council option thank you very much
your time contribution this evening
let's call for our next speaker who is
Mr Mark Eaton
good evening Mr Eden
uh you again will have three minutes
I'll give you 30 second one for your
time is up um if you're sat ready come
through and good to go press the button
on the right it will go red and the
floor is yours
I'm representing 65 Welford residents
and families who felt strong enough to
record 76 letters of planning based
objections to this application
I'd like to counter the planning report
assessment the conclusions in three key
areas
firstly as a principle of development
welfare Villages now by any measure
significantly overdeveloped and out of
line with policies hlu one cs16 and cs15
as of the 31st of March 2022 Welford was
at 189 versus its original dwelling
Target in the site allocation plan with
nine years yet to go
and this is not in line with the
balanced dispersal policy even if the
targets are guidelines 189 or 157 after
a 20 adjustment it's not marginal it's
massively over
and with recent further approvals such
as the 24 dwelling kelstein development
further up Barton Road the over
development will grow by at least
another 25 percentage points
this matters because no infrastructure
investment to support this cumulative
development has taken place and this has
led to increased surface water flooding
and sewage exposure across the village
and specifically adjacent to this site
where residents have already been
identified by the flood Authority as
having raised flood risk and seven
trends for sewage blockages receiving
letters from both agencies respectively
secondly the application site at the low
point of two gradients into and out of
the village is recorded as a high
surface water Risk by the government
and to develop it does not seem to be in
line with CS4 water environment and
flood risk
the initial objection from the local
flood Authority has been replaced with
three very complicated conditions which
will be very difficult to police and
will not be sustainable in the climate
emergency environment declared by the
council
these significant and clearly identified
flood risks should be resolved if they
can be resolved before any planning
Grant
thirdly the application absolutely does
have a big impact on the landscape and
character of the area out of line with
policy hlu5 garden and back Land
Development
the proposed development is clearly far
more dense than the existing adjacent
residencies
with a significantly higher proportion
of dwellings placed onto the site
the committee report example cited on
another part of Barton Road had no
impact on existing residents and is not
relevant to this development
closer more relevant development has
only three dwellings on a similar size
plot
the whole site will significantly
increase noise reduce privacy and
detriment immunity for all existing
adjacent residents
in conclusion our request on behalf of
the 65 objecting residents that the
committee consider these planning-based
objections and move to refuse this
application
you finished dead on your time I'm so
glad you did I was so absorbed in what
you were saying I completely forgot to
give you a 30 second warning so I
apologies for that members do we have
any questions
no Mr Wheaton thank you very much for
your time contribution this evening
okay we will call our next speakers who
are
Mr Julian Walker we have Miss Liz
Nicholson and we have Mr Ted wake who I
believe is going to be answering
questions
ah
I'm very sorry but I don't think we're
going to be able to wait so we will
crack on without him okay so um Mr
cousin I'm assuming you're going to do
most of the speaking
okay do you want to have do you want me
to let you know when the time is at a
certain point or you just have to let
you go and I'll give you your 30 seconds
before you're done you have six minutes
in total so it will be I'll give you the
30 seconds before
feel free to use as much or a little of
the six minutes as you need
um whenever you'll come from ready to go
flaws yours
okay uh thank you very much
um I won't keep you long ladies and
gentlemen
um I'm here I'm Julian Walker I work for
brookworth homes I'm here to just
introduce us as a developer and uh
answer any questions you may have about
us
um and then I'll hand over to Liz to
talk about the planning side of things
um we are a genuinely high quality
developer I know you've probably heard
that a lot from various people we do
genuinely strive to be better we look to
deliver more and to deliver houses that
people are genuinely proud of that is in
terms of their design the amount of room
that is provided
um the quality of the bills the
materials the fixtures and fittings we
want and the public realm we want this
to be a high quality develop development
we look to raise the bar in every
development that we work on and I hope
that if you approve this Scheme tonight
that you will be very pleased with the
result that you get from us and I want
hand over to Liz to talk about the
planning application
thank you
Holmes is Union was saying we've we're
hard with your officers design a high
quality scheme
and addresses all the technical points
that have been raised by consultees
along the way amended plans have been
provided to address design and layout
concerns that were raised by officers
because of the shortage of time here are
focused on some of the key points that
we've dealt with but obviously we're
happy to answer questions on any of
these matters or anything else
whilst we're aware the concerns
expressed about housing numbers in
Welford during the plan period your
published revised preferred options site
allocations plan says this it's
important to remember that the course
strategy does not restrict additional
housing in any or all circumstances and
there are a number of instances where
proposals for additional homes will be
policy compliance and therefore granted
planning consent
in summary these include within the
built-up area of the main town a main
Rural Center or a local service Village
in accordance with policy cs16
this statement clearly applies to the
scheme before you tonight and it's
further supported by a made neighborhood
development plan that supports new
Housing Development within the built of
area boundary and it's supported by
recent appeal decisions
so as I was saying the scheme has
evolved through the planning process the
original scheme submitted to officers
for pre-application advice proposed 23
smaller houses
however officers were concerned that
these proposals were out of character
with the surrounding area which is a low
density area generally large detached
houses with substantial Gardens
so the current proposals for just nine
dwellings have addressed this initial
concern
we did present the scheme for nine
dwellings to the parish council at their
meeting in May 2022 before the formal
application was submitted where possible
we have sought to address some of the
points raised in that meeting but some
of the requests were not within our gift
to deliver so I know that it's been
talked about about the footpath but that
would require the use of third-party
land and it wasn't possible to do that
we're also aware that drainage is a key
local issue and foul water from this
scheme will discharge into the existing
seven-trent water combined sewer on the
western boundary of the site
seven Trent Waters have confirmed that
there is capacity to make this
connection
surface water will be discharged at a
controlled rate into the existing
culverted Watercourse in Barton Road and
flood storage is provided in a tank
underneath the private shared Drive
in the village Network the site is
Downstream from the main area of concern
for the village and we've worked very
closely with the llfa to ensure that we
have their support for the proposals
turning to landscape and biodiversity
there are significant Landscaping
buffers proposed along the northern and
western boundaries of the site there's
both native tree and understory planting
species have been chosen for their local
provenance biodiversity benefit robust
nature and ability to easily establish
providing a visual link to the existing
vegetation within the local landscape
as well as the on-site biodiversity
measures a financial contribution of
about 130 000 pounds will be made to
off-site biodiversity enhancement
with the agreement of the county
ecologists this money could be spent
locally within the village and I know
that has been done before with some of
the schemes in the past
finally with regards to climate change
your council's checklist has been
completed and submitted it brings
together a lot of the information in the
proposals to show how the development
provides a great number of local and
National policy requirements
there is a section 106 agreement and
obviously conditions proposed and these
secure matters such as water boats cycle
storage Superfast Broadband pedestrian
accessibility and safety electric
vehicle charging points drainage
infrastructure sustainable construction
and a financial contribution to
affordable housing
so in conclusion the principle of
building nine new homes which is a Net
game of eight dwellings on the site
within the settlement boundary of the
village is in accordance with the
development plan and there are no
technical grounds on which to refuse the
application and we would therefore ask
that the development be supported thank
you
thank you very much both well within
your time members do we have any
questions for our applicant and agent
please councilor Curtis
thank you very much chair
um I think it is
um you mentioned that uh seven Trent
uh says they have the capacity to make
this connection for the foul water
um
it says in the report that there has
been have been incidents of flooding
from sewers so I'm just wondering
well those 17 may be saying they've got
the capacity to make the connection will
any additional capacity to cope with the
additional outflow from these properties
be provided
no and I wish Ted was here and not stuck
on the motorway but I mean what seven
Trent water is saying is that the
capacity needed for this scheme there is
that capacity within the system that it
exists it exists there already
um I would think that there are problems
if it's combined to a where surface
water is coming in and obviously we're
not allowed to increase the risk in
terms of surface water so that's where
we've done a lot of work with the llfa
we've gone backwards and forwards to be
fair we've had three or four rounds
we've had meetings with them as well and
we've resolved the issues with surface
water so that that is managed properly
without that impact on the combined
sewer
but there thank you chair but there is
still the question that has been
flooding from sewers in the village
hasn't there
but my understanding
um as best as I understand it from from
the dialogue that's been going on this
is Downstream of where the problems have
been in the village and I do know that
separately the LFA um has met with the
village and when I asked about that they
said well it's nothing to do with your
site it's completely separate issue
within the village so I know that's
going on separately
Council Adam
thank you um I think previous speakers
indicated that you've uh consulted with
the the local community
um but seemed to raise concerns that not
many um
of their concerns were listened to could
you sort of just elaborate on the type
of consultation that you have carried
out with the local religion if any
concessions were made by your scheme um
actually when thinking about communities
committee we we went to the parish
council meeting we presented the
proposals we had a question and answer
session so that's that's what we did
um the comments that they kindly sent to
us afterwards there were nine points if
you want me to I'll go through all of
them
um one of them was a general point about
housing numbers one of them was about
the red line including the land at the
top which was to remain open so we've
put that in the blue line
um I know one of them is about Bungalows
we have got two Bungalows two two
bedroom Bungalows within the mix yes the
Bungalows are the bedrooms are upstairs
but you could easily within that layout
put a bedroom downstairs if you wished
so there are two bungalows in this in
this site and we have got a mix of
houses there's three four beds four
three beds and two two beds
um we have brought Ridge Heights down I
know that was a concern uh designer
materials we've liaised with the
planning officer so we've made changes
through the course of the process and
obviously the condition for final
details
um they would have liked a property
fronting if you go back to the layout
they would have liked property fronting
onto Barton Road
um but you can't quite see it on on that
um
but it's it's just not possible because
we have to get the alignment of the
junction right for Highway Safety it's
not possible to fit a house in right on
the bottom Road Frontage without it
being very narrow fronted and looking
odd and and so that was agreed with the
planning officer who also raised it it
was better to leave that Land open
um connectivity yes they did ask for the
footpath linking on this side but it
would have involved third-party land so
we couldn't do that uh Landscaping we
have provided all the details in the
planning applications so they've seen
those and the condition is just that
we're in accordance with those
um and they did ask for construction
management plan to be submitted with the
application but we need to leave that
for conditions because until contractors
are appointed it's very hard to do that
one
before bringing councilor Crump you
mentioned Bungalows is it fair to say
given that the bedroom is upstairs that
it's story and a half rather than single
or double is that yeah the bedrooms are
on on the first floor yeah where they're
within the roof space yeah okay thank
you Council Crump
thank you Mr chairman yes very briefly
um in the conditions 19 and 20
um is a report in writing by suitably
qualified independent Chinese engineer
um but in number 20 aside specific
maintenance plan I'd just be interested
what that would like and how is that
likely to pan out
um please again I wish Ted was here
from my experience on other sites
because this is all fairly new as the
drainage requirements have ratcheted up
in the last 12 months
um what they require is to know
um exactly where the boundaries are
between private ownership of drainage
within the individual plots and where it
is underneath say an adopted highway or
where it's in an area managed by a
management company and then you have to
provide the details of the contact
person at the management company or
confirm its adopted highway or it's in
the private ownership so I think that's
that's what it's about
councilor Harvey please
thank you chairman why are there no
affordable houses amongst the nine
simply because they're not required by
policy if it had been the 23 dwelling
scheme first proposed then they would
have been on site
any other questions before we move to
our next speakers
no in that case both of you thank you
very much your time and contribution
this evening
okay we'll call on last week on this
item who's Council the purse together
okay you know the drill you've got five
minutes I'll give you 30 second warning
when you're comfortable sat ready to go
press the button on the right and the
floor is yours
uh good evening members yeah
I would have liked the developer to have
engaged with the parish council in
relation to the Village housing needs
one of site contribution for affordable
housing is not appropriate and this
provision or policy for offsetting
affordable housing should not be used
lightly inevitably no affordable house
will be built off-site in Welford as a
result of this development
most importantly I would have like the
developers to engage with the
neighboring residents to protect their
amenity the proposed dwellings will
bring a significant overdevelopment of
the plot at the moment the scheme
proposes houses which we look directly
into the neighboring Gardens or
properties facing Headland Road this is
in conflict with our NDP policy hul5
background development
regarding numbers the NDP clearly states
that all development proposals in
Walford and Avon will therefore have
regard to the approximate number of 84
houses
our Villa just seen a large increase in
development and is at around 200
planning applications granted for new
dwellings to date these nine houses are
proposed in the same location the same
road as the 24 houses which have been
approved on the kelstein site
we feel that the cumulative effect of
small and medium development in the
village is not been taken into
consideration by the local planning
Authority indeed if we take the
council's own tally or built and
committed houses in the village 159 to
March 2021 and even allowing for a 20
adjustment which takes us to 101
required houses this still equates as we
head at 157 percent difference for
achieving balance dispersal the report
mentions the inspector's remarks on an
appeal on Western house in relation to
numbers but that is not comparable as
the application was for four dwellings
only
this increase in housing a suddenly not
be complemented by improvements in
infrastructure and as such is of great
concern to the Village
the proposed scheme will produce a
substantial loss of biodiversity
the current calculation is a loss of
3.330 units there isn't a provision for
a biodiversity net gain plan in the
scheme and the proposed Financial
contribution for offsetting by Borussia
County Council shows the scale of
biodiversity laws
the mppf states the one determining
planning applications local planning
authorities should aim to conserve and
enhance biodiversity as it stands the
proposed development to negatively
impacts on biodiversity I would apply to
see measures taken to work on on the
natural assets of the site to produce a
biodiversity net gain this might very
well mean to have a less dense
development green open spaces and to
retain the many trees which are proposed
to be failed with the loss of
biodiversity The Proposal is contrary to
policy CS2 and CS5
further the flood maps from the
environment agency showed that this
development site is a high risk from
surface water flooding
modern check development will put both
the six existing and new dwellings at a
higher risk of flooding at this location
and we had serious sewage failings on
Barton Road back in February the local
flood Authority is subsequent to no
objection is conditional of the
submission of a detailed surface water
drainage scheme which means that the
current plan by the developer is clearly
insufficient to manage and to mitigate
increased flood risk a detailed
suds-based scheme is required the plans
only show infiltration range permeable
Paving and the storage tank what other
measures have been considered for
example swales ponds Ritz beds rain
Gardens soccerways and where is the
assessment of these measures who's going
to maintain this Suds the existing water
course the Culvert already floods there
is nothing in the plant to show impact
on flooding or to mitigate additional
flood risk so the proposal is in
conflict with policies 4 and NDP policy
H in H9 flood risk I ask that the
application in its current form is
refused or at least a decision deferred
until the conditioned Suds scheme has
been authorized perhaps abducted by the
local flood Authority thank you
Council pass again a well within your
time thank you very much members do we
have any questions for our counselor
no council Harvey I don't know whether
this is a fair question but I will ask
nevertheless
um have you got any information locally
about the demand for places on the
school
um not Locker I mean I don't but um I
know that we I must the we got 200
and the the capacity is 250 and I think
we are at 267 at the moment with
children so we are over capacity at the
moment of the school
cancer Curtis
thank you
um thank you
um we have a climate change emergency at
the moment you
and gave some very interesting detail
about the biodiversity gain that you
would like to see and you also mentioned
a number of mature trees how many
material trees do you know need to be
filled for this iteration of this
application I don't have the number at
all but I know that
on on that side there are quite a few
trees that will be felt uh they have to
be felt there is planting plants but as
you know you know the planting the small
trees will take quite a long time to
you know achieve the carbon culture of
mature trees
perhaps clarify that and with officers
shortly yeah any other questions members
no Council post together thank you very
much for time contribution
now we do of course now we have no more
speakers so we'd of course move into
points of clarification with our
officers uh Council Curtis would you
like to ask about the trees
could you put your microphone on if you
wouldn't mind
thank you yes um I think you know I'd
like to know what types of committee
we'd like to know as well how many trees
would need to be felled for this for
this iteration of the plan
um and also can I just ask for
clarification
sorry page 14.
the second to last line no objection
from the LFA
subject to the three conditions could we
have a little more information about
what those three conditions might be
thank you chair
thank you councilor to answer your first
question about the trees taken from the
applicant submission 11 category sea
trees would be failed to facilitate the
development and 14 category C groups
Hedges scrub that's how they're
described to be removed
and to answer your second question
sorry I'm turning to page 25 of the
agenda
um
so the conditions are sort of separated
by their triggers so um let me just a
quick look condition six is one of the
llfa recommended conditions condition
20.
and
thank you
19 yes they're the three conditions
recommended by the llfa
and then the two notes are within the
consultation responses but I can find
those if that would be helpful okay
councilor Adam please
thank you um had a couple of queries
um
first one would be
um they somewhat relate to the
neighborhood development plan just for
context
um the first one was similar similar
density to immediate neighborhoods
reference and I think their report notes
that the southern side of Barton Road
um is what's used to sort of justify
that this is similar but I know concerns
were raised that it was a higher density
than its immediate neighbors so it's
just around that
um
uh and then I was going to ask about
Bungalows um if you know what I suppose
we'll go for one at a time that's right
sorry so the density compared to
yeah
that's okay
um so the density is being considered
appropriate in the context of the
village like plan might be helpful in uh
showing the surrounding density of
development
um and
return to this Slide the top right is
the Dormer Bungalows it's been described
it does have a combination at the first
floor and the bedrooms I can show you
that two seconds
um
I think it's that one yes that's plots
one and nine
um the housing mix has been considered
appropriate in the context and the scale
of the scheme obviously these smaller
scale developments it's it's difficult
to get the percentages exactly right but
um we consider it's appropriate in this
instance Richard I don't have anything
to add
um no I'll just reiterate what Sarah
said around when you get to these very
small numbers it's very hard to hit
those percentages bang on
um and and they are it's not an exact
science but we feel that this is a
fairly good mix in relation to what the
policy says
foreign
very slight follow-up then in terms of
the Bungalow aspect
um the sort of answer we had from the
applicant representative was
um they are Bungalows but the bedrooms
are all on the first floor which
isn't how I Define a bungalow
what is our accepted definition of a
bungalow and is there capacity for it to
have bedrooms on the first floor or is
it
I think we've been through this on
previous applications but it still
doesn't sit very well with me so is
there some clarity that we can have on
that sort of definition how it's put
together
device
I can't give you a hard and fast rule on
what a bungalow is I would look at these
and say they were Dormer Bungalows other
people might say it's two-story it's not
a bungalow it's a two-story house but
there's no definition in any planning
law of what a bungalow is
would it be helpful if we got a rough
idea of the height compared with the
other houses or is that not going to be
helpful to you
uh no not noria height for me it's more
of a sort of capacity of where the rooms
are in the in terms of stories
understood uh cancer Eden next please
thank you chair
um two from me if you don't mind
um the first is the road that's serving
those properties I couldn't really tell
from the
um picture is that a single track or
double track it kind of looks like
single with some passing points
do you know I believe it's a single okay
a truck Road yes there's a visitor Park
uh visit a parking space
it's there if you can see it but I
believe it's single track yeah
oh okay
sorry
can we just check that oh
so I'm sharing right okay I suspect it's
probably uh double track but we'll we'll
just double check that
did you want do you want to ask your
second question while that's being
checked uh if if you don't mind yeah um
the second question was Ryan condition
17.
which is around
um the provision of a crossing point
um what is a crossing point in this sort
of circumstance is it a drop curb or is
it something more than that
I think I'll probably have to check what
the County Highway Authority has said in
their response in order to give you a
view on that so just bear with me I'm
sorry for the awkward question
The Crossing points referred to in the
county highways response and then it
refers to a particular plan so we think
we can show you that plan and show you
the details of what that crossing point
is
can answer to your question about the
width of the road
um I haven't measured it but it's
roughly the same as a parking Bay depth
which would be just under five meters so
it's wide enough for two cars to pass it
in no circumstances of what you see
there
um passing and waiting Bays they're
parking Bays the bits on the side so
it's a two-way Road
and this is the plan that the highways
response referred to so
I believe the crossing point will be I
don't know if you can see my cursor
around here
okay
um Council Jennings next please
yes thank you chairman
sorry
yeah just a quick clarification on these
categories of trees and things I'm
presuming category C is the lowest grade
or the highest grade
I believe category U is the lowest grade
of classification and it goes up to a
being the best quality tree so see
somewhere in the middle
thank you
Council Harvey please thank you Jim I've
got two questions
um I asked the agent why there were no
affordable houses on the basis of the
parish council were Keen to see
affordable houses the reply that I got
was it's not required by policy which I
thought was a very good answer do I take
it then that is it as far as
affordable housing on this particular
site it complies with policy there is a
payment to be made for off-site
affordable housing elsewhere end of
matter is that correct
thank you for your question we're just
getting the policy up now um
Richard
yeah
the key policy here is policy cs18 about
affordable housing
um and under a certain threshold that
threshold being 11 homes
um it's acceptable to have an off-site
provision which is what you've got in
front of you tonight uh and that
complies with your policy cs18 on
affordable housing
thank you very much that's a very clear
answer my second question relates to
flooding and and drainage councilor
bertagella in her statement that we've
been given in the update sheet says the
village has a combined drainage system
meant for a much smaller settlement and
it cannot cope with further development
she has a very clear view there is a
problem
your report suggests that the whatever
problems there are there are there are
acceptable ways of getting around them
is that the case
I would say that's correct yes and the
lead local flood authority of Lee local
flood Authority initially objected to
the scheme and threw amendments and
additional information submitted by the
applicant it was considered acceptable
providing those three conditions were
attached for submission of
some drainage plan and further details
okay councilor Foreman please
thank you when you're talking
the um off-site affordable housing
contribution will that money be spent
guaranteed to be spent in Welford or
just somewhere else in the district
I would defer to Richard for
that question
I'm not sure I'm going to be able to
answer that question tonight not without
doing a bit of research if if you could
give me perhaps five minutes whilst
other questions are asked I could dig
into that to see if there's some detail
of what the Cascade mechanism might or
might not be
I'm not sure there are any other hands
up if I'm honest does anyone else have
any questions
do you want to take a quick five minute
breather while Richard looks into that
and we can get a definitive answer
yeah
so we're just gonna just
what's the word I'm looking for
adjourn my brain's functioning really
well right now we're just going to
adjourn for five minutes
um and then we'll be back when Rich has
gone answer
foreign
uh from our offices so members if you're
already
huh
thank you Mr chairman having had a look
um at the SPD on this matter there's no
requirement for Cascade or ring fencing
mechanism to Welford because we're
talking about a district-wide need for
affordable housing here however if I can
give members some comfort
um our housing policy team always as a
starting point look to deliver the need
where the the
the money has arisen in this case in
Welford so they would look to do that as
a first Port of Call and look to deliver
sites as close as possible to where that
need is Arisen But ultimately it is a
district-wide need so it could there's
no guarantee that it could
um couldn't be spent elsewhere in the
district
okay thank you very much any other
points for clarification or questions to
our officers before we move to the
debate
no let's move to debate who would like
to kick us off
I'm going to start pointing fingers
Council Adam please
thank you
um I suppose I'll start by saying I
think there are things there are some
merits to this and then I think that uh
the comment from the applicant that they
are looking to produce high quality
dwellings is important to note because
we have seen poor quality across the
district not necessarily within our gift
to stop but you know I'm encouraged that
that is a an aim that they've set out to
do that being said there are concerns
that I have over the
some of the specifics and I'd say it's
more of a an accumulation of smaller
points which gives me a
a bad feeling about it as opposed to
kind of one over over ruling one I think
the the obvious one which is in my mind
is the Bungalows aspect uh which relates
to the housing mix
um
and I think
from my point of view it's how that
relates to the neighborhood development
plan
uh
now you know I've got a neighborhood
development plan that's just been
improved in my ward and I know how hard
for after they are and how specific they
are when when regarding that
uh I also know that if if
um bedrooms are on a first floor it
doesn't really accommodate the
definition of what I'd call a bungalow
to accommodate the function that that
neighborhood development plan was likely
looking for I'm not satisfied on that
basis the housing mix as is set out
therefore meets the neighborhood
development plans requirements based on
you know how they were looking at it
how much weight that is given
um
I I can appreciate might not be enough
to overrule it on on the the finer
balance but it certainly adds to other
things which have been raised such as
the drainage
um being a major concern for some the
only other thing which I will add
would be that I think
the point being made about the housing
numbers in Welford in general does
concern me
I know we've visited this before a
number of times on a number of
applications and I know that the appeal
decision that we refer to a number of
times on a number of applications is
relevant but I still maintain that
10 percent is not around 20 or not
approximately 20 or whatever it might be
I think it is reasonable for us as the
local planning authority to challenge
that when we are looking at applications
for settlements which are in my
definition over developed and so I would
give that more weight when looking at
applications of this type
uh
I won't make a proposal to go against at
the moment but that's the way I'm going
on the basis of those aggregate pieces
of information adding up
uh I'm being treated to see what other
members feel
cancer Jennings please
and I think this is a an exceptionally
comprehensive report and I think I think
the officers should be uh congratulated
for that
um there's in my view there seems to be
a lot of liaison with the
with the builders and so it's moved from
23 houses down to nine
um I'm looking through all and if we
want to object to a planning application
we have to have
very sound material planning reasons to
do so I'm looking through this and I
think this this proposal is small scale
um in policy CR 16 and the housing
numbers as we as we uh found out in many
occasions there is no maximum but this
is say this is nine
um you're going I go through everything
else the design or impact to the
landscape ticks the Box
um
again on
residential immunity to me it ticks is
the Box uh housing mix it ticks the Box
whether it's a bungalow or Dormer
Bungalow if there's no definition we
have to go on what's what what's in
front of us and if if they're both if
they're both seen by in planning terms
as being the same we have to we have to
accept that
um affordable housing again that's been
addressed
um when it comes to trees Landscaping
it's grade C they have I'm sure there'll
be conditions in there but they're
they're going to be replacement trees
drainage
um comes back to the llfa they're the
experts and we have to go with what the
experts tell us
um and they have set out a number of
conditions here
um
and going through it I see no material
planning reason to go against it so I'm
going to say
um
I'm going to go and I would like to
propose that we go along with the
officer's recommendation and approve
this application
thank you cancer Jennings cancer Kendall
please
thank you chairman
uh yes I think I can completely agree
with Watson said I mean the one the big
thing that came to me was all about over
development and I was trying to work out
is this Nova developed onto the site
tonight I can't remember if I've seen
this application site before but I was
shocked to hear that the original
proposal or the original design was for
23 houses which would have easily been
over developed to this site but this is
a much a much reduced plan
and looking at the development you can
see a number of detached garages there's
clearly room for more than nine houses I
would argue 23 is ridiculous but you
know I think I think this is a
reasonable use of space to be honest
with you and I'm also pleased to see
that the developers have tried to engage
with the local parish as well offside
affordable housing Ridge heights were
reduced to Bungalows or whether you
think they're Bungalows or not but they
they are two bed smaller houses
um open space within the blue line I
think it's a reasonable development
I can't find the material planning
grounds to go again so I will second the
proposal to Grant thank you Council
Kendall Council Curtis next please
thank you chair
um
Council Jenning said that the um
affordable housing
has been addressed I I don't quite think
it has because I think what the officers
said was that you look the council looks
to deliver affordable sites within the
area or community in which these this
development would or developments would
be so I don't think we can take it as
read that affordable housing will
actually be developed on the site I
think it's interesting that I mean I I
agree with a lot of
um first comments around the the
cumulative problems around this
development I think it's very
interesting that the parish council
doesn't object per se to this
development and I think given the
welfare you know there should be around
12 percent of additional housing in any
develop such settlement wealth has taken
22.71 I don't think you know that that
is virtually double I don't think that
is approximately or around the original
figures
um
I think for me there's a problem there
is again a cumulative problem in welfare
that's been identified by the ward
member there that we have a a lot of
smaller
scale whatever small scale is
schemes that don't meet local housing
need they don't provide affordable
housing or the housing type and I think
I think we know what a bungalow is
actually
I think we know what sort of people want
to buy a bungalow they want a bedroom on
the first floor that's what a bungalow
is I think in in general acceptance
and
there's no guarantee that the
contribution to affordable housing is
going to be he's going to benefit
Wellford and help meet the neighborhood
development plan so I yeah I it's not
the worst scheme that's come to us by
any means but I have sufficient doubts
about the housing mix about the
cumulative impact on infrastructure that
I don't think I can support it
thank you very much Council Harvey
please
thank you chairman I think councilor
Curtis has just demonstrated that we
don't understand the same thing from the
same words when he referred to a
bungalow having a bedroom on the first
floor
I mean most of us will think about
ground floor correct
um that's an aside
um
I'm very conscious that the officers
have been through this and their
recommendation is
uh well thought through
I have nevertheless some concerns about
this is another incremental application
it's another nine houses and the people
who live locally in Welford are telling
us that
it's a bit upon a bit upon a bit
and the cumulative effect on the
infrastructure isn't always recognized
I've I've we've had the the ward member
uh
say that the system can't cope the
drainage system can't cope and yet the
advice is well no it can cope if we do
this that and the other so we're left
having to come to a view on that
um cs16 and the 13 and the number of
houses I I well understand
the the deities it has been held by the
courts repeatedly uh by by planning
inspectors if not the courts uh that it
is not a maximum it it is it is uh it's
it's a minimum and there is no maximum
but there for me there does come a point
where a settlement on an incremental
basis
can't accept
additional houses because somewhere
along the line the straw does break the
camel's back and that is going to be
different in different locations so you
can't say it's okay up to 200 or up to
220 percent or 250 percent
and yet I know I know what the the
planning inspector's answer is likely to
be
um so I have I have reservations
but in addition to 65 local residents
writing in objections that to me is I'm
not saying at all high quality I'm not
saying they're all done on sound
planning reasons but I suspect a lot of
them are and they're critical and they
don't want to see it
but I'm struggling to find a really
sound planning reason that I can
convince myself
why I should not follow the officer's
recommendation I say that with a degree
of reluctance
but nevertheless I can't see you I can't
for myself at the moment see a good
planning reason not to follow the
officer's recommendation
I think councilor Harvey cancel the
Crump next please
I did initially I think I was going to
be going against them
councilor Harvey and then the last few
sentences that he's almost been reading
my scripts but he won't be able to read
my writer I'm afraid
um I've got immense sympathy for
uh parishes towns you go through the mdp
policy uh to get the neighborhood plan
adopted and you know go through sweating
Blood Sweat and Tears to get it done
then sometimes it comes to planning
committee
and it's
not taken account as as we would like it
to be but there are many reasons for
that we've talked about the numbers and
we've had the appeal decision
and
again I'm worried about the reasons for
for a refusal Council Harvey touched on
about the infrastructure and the the
last straw that the camel that broke the
camel's back but I'm not seeing the
evidence that's coming forward to say
the school's the chock-a-block
um delete local flood Authority
as the officer said Sarah said
originally objected to this
and then you know obviously for various
different reasons and there's been
robust consultation
um and
agreements between the officers at the
county and here and they've come up with
three
robust and strong conditions
um and obviously they are the leads for
the authority so they are the experts
certainly uh when it comes to affordable
housing that's not unused sometimes it
is offside and again I can fully
sympathize that
if welfare they're going to have the the
pain of these extra houses there should
be some benefit in return and it might
not necessarily be the case I'll
understand the frustrations and
certainly I would like to see something
which helps road safety and and whether
that could have been amended but again
um it was outside the control of
the applicant so again I'm slightly
disappointed about that so I'm not
particularly happy about it but I'm
worried about our reasons for a refusal
are not robust enough
and I'm worried
if that was the case and we've refused
this one we would lose this on a pill so
thank you very much
cancer Edmond please
thank you um I think a lot of councils
have said a lot of things about how I
feel uncomfortable generally with it but
it's hard to resist the only thing that
I would add that would tip me towards
going with the grant
was there anything that we can do from a
condition's point of view around this
crossing point because councilor
Appleton said about the children having
to cross the road possibly twice four
times a day
and
giving them the development that they
need or the infrastructure that they
need is there anything that we can do
from that point of view
to tick that box at the very least
cancer curses last one
thank you I think I know what you're
going to say in response to what I'm
going to say now it really does concern
me that we have so many conditions and
I'm looking particularly at the flood
prevention the conditions 6 19 and 20.
I'm reluctant to say this but there
we don't as a council
always ensure that these conditions are
adequately met and I'm reluctant to
approve something when there are just so
many conditions
attached to it that we cannot guarantee
now I know you'll say that's enforcement
that's not planning but I'm just
expressing that view
um
I think you I understand your point
um in reality most planning applications
come with an array of conditions
um I've seen a lot more than 20 however
many there are here 20 or 34 in fact
um on on on these things um and given
that they're directed by the experts who
provide us with evidence
um I I think we're hard-pressed to go
against that
um these of course these conditions are
in some cases pre-commencement some
cases preoccupancy they have to be
signed off by the council before they
can go forward so I I I'm not sure I
agree with you where you say that the
council don't do enough to make sure
that they are met I think the council do
do enough to make sure that they're met
they are a requirement as part of the
planning planning
um application if of course granted to
be signed off before commencement of the
development
um cancer Jennings last one please I'm
just saying if we're still in debata
surely conditions are good because it
means we're scrutinizing in these
applications in detail
I don't disagree
um I think we've we've debated it to
death
um we have got a proposal to Grant a
number without his recommendation it has
been seconded so could I please have a
show of hands for those in favor of
granting in line with the officer's
recommendation
five
and those against
four and abstentions
one committee therefore resolves to
Grant application 22
02351 ful one acre in Barton Road in
Wellford upon Avon
okay thank you very much for that let's
move on to our next application which is
application reference
2202770 very that is Orchard Lodge
Caravan Park in Barton uh part of
bidford Pon Avon our presenting officer
is Amy flute
and Amy as soon as you're set up and
ready to go the floor will be yours
thank you chairman the application site
denoted by the black dot is an existing
Caravan Park in the village of Barton
the site edged red is served by an
existing access off Wellford Road the
site adjoins the conservation area which
is this purple line
the site is in close at proximity to
several listed buildings which are
colored red on the plan and public
footpath al-27 adjoins the site's North
and eastern boundary which is this green
dotted line
The Proposal seeks to bury the original
consent to extend the use of the site so
that it can be used for Holiday use 12
months of the year in addition to the
installation of six additional Caravans
the existing and proposed site plans can
now be seen the additional Caravans
would be within the central grass area
and to the west of the site
this image is taken within the site
looking in a Westerly Direction the
grass Central Area can be seen which is
the proposed location for Caravans
again looking in a Westerly Direction
where two Caravans are proposed to be
cited
and this image is taken looking East
back into the site towards the site's
access so the access is approximately
here and you can see the relationship
with other Caravans on the site
chairman it is considered that the
variation being sought is considered to
be small scale and the extension of the
use for 12 months of the year for
Holiday purposes will not cause
unacceptable harm chairman the
recommendation is to Grant the
application subject to conditions and
notes as detailed within the committee
report please also note an update on the
update sheet thank you
Amy thank you very much indeed let's
call our first speaker on this item who
is counselor Taylor of Bitcoin Nathan
Parish Council
good evening councilor Taylor thank you
for your patience
that you've got an idea of how this is
going to go so you'll have three minutes
when your satin come from ready to go
the floor is yours I will give you
obviously a 30 second warning for your
time is up so when you're ready button
on the right to the floor is yours
right
um yes I'm speaking for Barton Parish
Council
uh partners are conservation at bidford
Parish Council Barton is a conservation
Hamlet of about 40 residential homes and
either side of those homes are two
Caravan Parks which you would have seen
in that map with a total of 54 mobile
home pitches six more Lodges at Orchard
Caravan Park will bring the total number
of mobile homes to 60. that's 60 mobile
lodges compared to 40 regular homes 60
lodges not playing council tax
at the Eastern end of the village Dove
cook Riverside Park with 38 pitches is
open for 10 months of the year and
closed for two and the residents observe
this at the other end is Orchard Lodge
the one we're talking about today which
is also only allowed to be open for 10
months of the year at the moment but
flats this rule
the planning officer's recommendation
that the site is open for the full 12
months of the year has been flagged by
the council's own licensing department
as being extremely difficult to enforce
just this year the owners have been
issued a warning from SDC for not
enforcing the enclosure the closure in
January and February
it's widely recognized that these
Caravans are the primary residents for
the majority of their owners the hope
that additional Caravans would increase
tourism unfortunately doesn't hold up
an increase from 16 homes to 22 is a 28
increase on a small site on the very
edge of a conservation Village the
planning officer considers they will
cause no harm to the setting of The
Conservation Area the homes used to be
well hidden surrounded by trees and
bushes but the landscape's already being
decimated to clear the way for
additional new pitches so from the
fields of the heart of England footpath
the Caravans are now in full view where
before there was a thick ring of mature
trees and shrubs around the boundary
as you see from the photos I mean if
they can be flicked through I'm talking
the access for the site is narrow it's
an unadopted Road and wasn't taken into
account by highways who were only
looking at the impact on the Welford
Road the impact on the environment of
large lorries bringing in and taking
away mobile homes is already clear to
see
this Lane is a well-used footpath used
by hikers dog walkers and fishermen and
for parking for by local residents and
visitors
the report mentions the support of three
residents they're all from one family
and two of whom live in one of The
Lodges every other Comet was an
objection from 11 other householders one
wanted to speak today but unfortunately
it was too late in putting their
application in
so in summary sdc's own licensing
department acknowledges that an
extension to allow holiday occupation to
12 months the year is not enforceable
which means that all current Caravans
would in effect become permanent new
dwellings and there would be six
additional new dwellings
bidford's NDP policies H1 and H2
classified Barton as Countryside and
limit development there unless there are
rural exceptions EG for Rural workers or
replacement dwellings Barton has no
infrastructures to support new housing
so bidford Parish Council requests that
this application be refused
Council Taylor thank you very much for
within your time members do we have any
questions for cancer Taylor please
no in that case cancel thank you very
much your time and contribution this
evening thank you let's call our next
speaker on the item who is speaking on
behalf of the applicant Mr Nick leister
good evening Miss Leicester again I
think you've probably got an idea of how
this is going to work so you'll have
three minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning when you're ready the floor is
yours
okay thank you for the opportunity to
speak I represent the owners of the site
we concur with your officer's overall
assessment of The Proposal as well as
the suggested planning conditions The
Proposal will enable the Caravan Park to
cater for the increased demand post
covid for people staying in
self-catering Holiday accommodation
economically as a result of both the
modest increase in the number of holiday
units and allowing all the units to be
occupied for Holiday purposes at any
time of the year it will help to boost
tourism spend in the area and Safeguard
or create local jobs in particular for
example we know that the landlady of the
adjacent Pub has expressed support
highlighting that the proposal would
give them extra customers at a very
difficult time including during January
and February uh and there has been
support from other third parties as the
committee report highlights no technical
objections have been raised by highways
Environmental Health licensing seven
Trends or the environment agency
the parish council has objected as we've
just heard based on its assumption that
the Caravans would in effect become
permanent new dwellings that would
contravene relevant policies applicable
to new housing in response we would
highlight that current national and
local planning policies make a clear
distinction between visitor
accommodation use and permanent
residential use in this instance the
principle of additional holiday units in
this Countryside location without any
restrictions on the period of occupation
comply specifically with policies cs24
and as10 which recognize the economic
and tourism benefits associated with
such development
a fresh revised planning condition has
been put forward which would be which
would prevent any of the Caravans from
being used as a solo main residence the
wording for this has been imposed by the
Council on permissions elsewhere
including here and otherwise meets the
nppf tests in terms of being necessary
relevant to the development to be
permitted enforceable precise and
reasonable in all other respects any
potential variation to the wording of
this condition to restrict the actual
period of holiday occupation would be
contrary to current policy objectives
that would fail the mppf tests for
conditions that would be inconsistent
with the approach taken by local
authorities and appeal inspectors
elsewhere
so finally in response to objections
raised by some other individual third
parties the information submitted with
the planning application demonstrates
that the proposal would not have a
materially adverse impact upon the
landscape trees and Wildlife
Conservation Area drainage and flooding
or immunity subject to the details of
supplementary landscaping and flood risk
being mitigated and controlled through
the conditions that are proposed as
regards traffic access and safety issues
the highway Authority concluded that the
scale of increase in the use of the
access is unlikely to be significant or
detrimental to the public Highway here
we would also highlight that the peak of
traffic flow times for Holiday use
differs to the main peak hours on the
highway Network and the holiday
occupation levels at the park would in
any event be highest during the main
holiday season when traffic levels
during normal peak hours are reduced
yeah I was going to say yes thank you
very much
lovely thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions for Mr
laser please councilor Jennings first
thank you Jim
um just a quick bit of clarification on
these Caravans
um are they fixed or are they all
movable they've got wheels on
they're all they are moving they're
static Caravans so they're on a chassis
and they have wheels
um but they do stand on a on a basically
a hard standing pad and in fact one of
the conditions that's been proposed is
to is to ensure that they are secured to
the ground because that's one of the
things the environment agency have asked
for that the the units are basically in
some way attached to the ground so that
if there is a flood event they wouldn't
move basically
Council Harvey
um I'm interested to know on occupancy
of the of the existing Caravans
because that may be
uh indicative of what might happen in
the future were this to be granted
up figures kept
for the times when each of these
Caravans is occupied by holiday makers
or otherwise
yes that's correct the applicant is a
member of the British holiday and home
parks Association you have to have a as
part of the agreement to be an
association you have to keep a record uh
basically a register of occupants who's
coming in who's going out and that
hasn't actually been requested as a
condition but it is a fairly common
condition to add a clause that says
holiday use only not to be used as a
solo main residence and to keep a
register that can be made available at
the request of the council it doesn't
need to be requested unless there's a
suspected issue so that's um that that
register is already being kept as of
today and that would obviously continue
you can
if we had that register in front of us
what would it tell us
I well I must admit it it was news to me
this evening that um units are being
used occupied outside the holiday period
I can't tell you 100 the term that there
hasn't been somebody
um staying there when they shouldn't
have done but there is a register so the
council can at any time I know there's
no requirement on the condition at the
moment but the counter can at any time
request to see that register because it
is part of the agreement that our client
has with the say the Holiday Homes
Association so uh that should hopefully
show that this that isn't happening but
if this if this permission is granted
there is obviously an opportunity to
strengthen that condition and add that
Clause to say
such that that register to be made
available at the council's request so
somebody raises an issue
the council could request to see it and
that wouldn't be a problem with our
clients at all
okay thank you very much members any
other questions can I say interesting
yeah thank you are there any provisions
to improve that road access
to the site
uh not as no not as part of this
application obviously the the highway
Authority were content about the
application but there are no uh fixed
proposals
cancer Curtis please looks really needs
a fair bit of repair thank you Council
Council Curtis please
thank you uh thank you Mr Leicester um I
mean when I was a kid used to enjoy
Caravan holidays a lot and obviously we
want to see holiday use we want to
support the visitor economy it's really
important
um can you tell me how many of those
Caravans currently on site are available
to for Holiday let's for I don't know
say a week or two
as far as I'm aware I mean um the way
most of these this type of Caravan site
operate is that the units are often are
usually privately owned that's not to
say units can't be made available for
other people to stay but um most of the
units would be privately owned Holiday
Homes
okay any other questions
nope selective thank you very much for
your time contribution this evening
okay our final speaker on this item is
councilor Pemberton
good evening councilor Pemberton you do
know the drill five minutes 30 second
warning when you're ready press the
button on the right the floor is yours
good evening chair good evening
committee members thank you for your
time in allowing me to to speak on this
application
um I understand here all of the parish
council's concerns and absolutely agree
with them
um in theory there's a register
in practice there's a register in theory
we can enforce in practice we're never
going to enforce enforcement is a
um discretionary service and this should
be so low on the priorities it's never
going to get to the top
um all of those things are true
members your chances of successfully
resisting this planning application in
full
members I'm asking you to Grant
permission for the extension in the
number of Caravans that does not
demonstrably cause any harm
um
it's a stretch to say that it will add
to the economy uh particularly of Barton
the pub doesn't open all the time
um and it's not that's not going to
change uh they're all going to be
private homes the real concern is about
occupancy so uh members I believe that
you are entirely in your rights to Grant
planning permission but to delete
condition three relating to occupancy
there is already a condition in place
for occupancy for 10 months of the year
which is perfectly adequate it does what
it says on the tin there is no
particular need
or planning gain
by allowing for 12-month occupancy
holidays are not defined so if we look
at the six planning tests
um
so is the condition around
the occupation necessary for the
planning application the substantive
part of the planning application is the
ex is the extra number of units you
don't it is therefore not necessary
to Grant the planning permission for the
extra units to have that condition there
is already an occupancy condition so
therefore is it relevant no is it
enforceable
theoretically yes practically now is it
precise no there is no definition of
holidays
um
is it reasonable in all of the respects
maybe maybe not but members you have a
perfectly workable condition that has
operated since 1980 there have been
challenges on this site around occupancy
you've already been told that they are
privately owned there's no great
economic benefit people let their maybe
their friends or close family and close
friends use these things but there's no
demonstrable benefit and the extra two
months really doesn't actually change
doesn't overcome the additional harm of
the potential for the site to be uh
somebody on a 51 week holiday so members
my uh ask of you as a committee is that
you grant but exclude condition three as
it relates to occupancy the current
occupancy condition is strong enough
works and I um
clear that that would be an outcome the
parish council would support as would
the residents of Barton happily take any
questions
members do you have any questions for
the Council of permanent
no in that case thank you for your time
contribution thank you chair
okay members let's move into points for
clarification with our officers do we
have anything that needs clarifying
Council Jennings first
yeah I just want a bit more
clarification on the on the use if it
does go from 10 to 12 months
um are these classified as permanent
dwellings and does that
um yeah just a bit more information on
that please
um so no the the use of the Caravans
they would remain as a holiday
accommodation and that's the purpose of
condition free which clearly states that
any of the Caravans cited on the site
um apart from one which does have um
permission for permanent um use by um a
worker of the site shall be used for
Holiday accommodation purposes and not
for any other residential use falling
within class C3 so
effectively we would be able to enforce
against that condition if somebody was
living on the site for
um all year round and not for Holiday
purposes
thank you very much
Council Harvey please
um
a statement Ron I have a question but my
statement I would have found it well
perhaps could you explain why this
application the information to support
it didn't include
information about the occupancy of the
existing units because
a critical test seems to me to be
whether these are holiday let's in the
sense that are used from time to time by
individuals of the same family or
whatever or whether they are really used
as as permanent homes de facto I would
have found that that that
um helpful but my question is a
consequence of that is
do you have any information concerning
families who take long holidays on the
site who actually have got children
registered in a local school
I don't have that information
um before me
my cons I'm just going to add to uh as a
response to what you said my concern
with worrying about what's happening on
the site now is that we're straying into
the enforcement side of things and the
regulatory side of things we have a
regulatory committee that keeps control
over that we're here to make a decision
on the planning application that's put
in front of us whilst I'm sure it would
be very helpful information we strain
slightly into enforcement and regulation
rather than what's put in front of us so
I just thought I'd make that known does
anyone else have any questions or points
that need clarifying cancel Adam please
thank you um the representative of the
applicant made reference to a potential
condition that they'd be willing to
um accept with regards to a register of
people who who used Caravans and the
duration of time that they use them for
is that something that you've considered
as part of
your recommendations or is that or is
that sort of new to you and you might be
willing to accept that as an additional
condition
um so
the license seeing comments which were
received there there was a suggestion
for a condition
um required to ensure the site remains
as a holiday site which did ask for a
register
um I think I think my concern would be
obviously that there's other legislation
that can cover
um the requirements for
um that kind of information also because
of the condition the condition that is
proposed does stipulate that sorry let
me just find it
um
that the a comment that the site
effectively shall only be used for
Holiday accommodation purposes only so
if there were any breaches then the
enforcement team would be able to
investigate and and request further
information to obviously establish
whether or not a breach to that
condition has occurred or not
Council curses
I think so
um yes I'm just looking at this page 37
um
the final paragraph you note that SDC
licensing has suggested a number of
conditions
and but you've omitted these conditions
I I think it might have been helpful for
the committee to see what conditions
like are you debating or are you asking
a question
um I think you're debating should we
open up debate and Council Curtis would
you like to kick us off thank you
um
I on on that specific point
um I think it would have been helpful
for the committee to
see what those conditions suggested by
licensing would have been I I take your
earlier
comment
um that we may be straying into
enforcement but
um I think it would have been relevant
perhaps to the committee to be able to
see what those conditions were and we
would be able to take a view on those
thank you understood um anyone else in
debate councilor Edmond please
um
from my point of view I think that uh
councilor Pemberton said it in a
nutshell in many respects it's there's
zero point or
ability to resist this or go against the
officer's decision should I say um I
think the conditions are sound as they
are and I like
the
condition number three
um to stay from my point of view but I
could be convinced otherwise
um so I'll propose that we go with grunt
as it stands please
thank you councilor Adam please
thanks I'm happy to Second uh councilor
Eden on that I think number condition
number three is something I would like
to see maintained
um
not least because as as per uh
Chairman's comments previously on a
previous application this evening you
know we do have the power to enforce and
it's important that we have the
conditions to ensure that
um and this is certainly one which seems
pertinent to uh to this site and uh
Elise goes hopefully some way to address
the parish council's concerns albeit
that they still object so uh yeah half a
second on that basis thank you very much
anyone else
Council engine seraphin yes sir I I
agree that uh condition three should
still remain
basically if 12 months is granted then
maybe people live there permanently not
as a holiday it would end up blood up
cancel Curtis please yes um I find
myself
um alarm say that I'm fully in agreement
with Council pemberton's proposal when
he spoke I agree with councilman
seraphim I think
um maintaining the condition three and
but allowing the additional Caravans on
site seems to be a perfectly reasonable
and elegant solution to this I don't
feel those additional two months are
going to really substantially benefit
the visitor economy so I would go with
the um boardrooms proposals
okay thank you
um
I'm going to try and get my head around
some of this it's getting a little
confusing
I think the proposal that has been
seconded is to Grant in line with the
officer's recommendation
no change to anything
I'm not sure I've heard anything that's
substantively gives me uh comfort that a
counter proposal has been put forward
um what I would say on the proposal to
our proposal are second that I
personally quite like the idea oh not
the ugly idea I think it's neater if we
do have within condition three
um a requirement uh to maintain that
register uh of the occupants uh when and
all that sort of stuff
um and have it available to the district
council so would you be willing to
accept a modification to that to include
the need to maintain that register and
have it available to the council upon
request I would share
yeah certainly that was one of the
reasons I asked a point of qualification
from the officer is because I was
intrigued by that so I'd certainly
support it marvelous okay in that case
unless anyone else's anything they want
to add to the debate we will move to a
vote no one okay so the proposal is to
Grant in line with officer
recommendation with a minor amendment to
uh condition three to include the need
for the uh register to be taken and
available upon request could I have a
show of hands for those in favor please
of granting
foreign
against
one so that's nine one so committee
therefore resolves to Grant application
2202 770 a very that's Orchard Lodge
Caravan Park in well uh in beautiful
Ivan in Barton sorry
um okay
let's move to our next item on the
agenda which is application reference
2300252 ful that is 11 Lawson Avenue in
tiddington our presenting officer will
be Sarah Leach in just a moment
okay so as soon as you're set up ready
to go the floor is yours
thank you chairman good evening this
proposal is seeking planning permission
for a single story route and part side
extension the application site is
located within tiddington as seen by the
black dot
the application site is located in a
residential area of tiddington and has
neighboring neighboring dwellings to all
boundaries
here we have the existing location plan
and proposed site plan
the dwelling currently has a single
sorry the dwelling currently has a
single story element to the rear The
Proposal will extend on the existing
element The Proposal also includes a
single story side extension to the front
elevation
this is the existing and proposed ground
floor plans showing the proposals in red
here are the existing sorry hit
here are the existing and proposed
elevations
these are some photographs of the
application site so from the front
elevation
the rear elevation
and the rear elevation so showing the
existing single story element
office's recommendation is to Grant this
application subject to conditions and
notes detailed within the report
Sarah thank you very much indeed we have
no registered speakers so we will open
up two points of clarification as anyone
anything clarifying no let's move into
debate who would like to kick us off
councilor Edmond was first
I see no reasons why we shouldn't go
along with this
um
I propose regret in line with officer's
recommendation thank you very much
Council Jennings
I'd like to suck that motion please The
Marvelous counselor Harvey you put your
hand up do you still wish to speak I
wanted to Second thank you we'll
consider you a third
um unless anyone else has anything they
want to say let's go to a vote so the
proposal is to Grants in London was off
the recommendation because I have a show
of hands for those in favor that appears
to be unanimous so committee therefore
resolves to Grant application
23.00252 ful 11 Lawson Avenue in
tiddington
marvelous let's move on to our final
application of the evening which is
application reference
2203210 ful Ulster Road in Stratford
Haven and our presenting officer will be
Victoria Kempton
Victoria as soon as you're ready the
floor will be yours
good evening and thank you chair
so this application is seeking
permission for the addition of a CCTV
camera to a Lamppost the application has
been bought to committee as it's
submitted on behalf of the District
Council
this plan shows a position of the site
which is just opposite the train station
to the west of the Town Center
in more detail the site is outlined in
red which is on the Ulster Road the dash
purple lines indicate the boundary of
other Ward areas whilst the solid purple
line shows the boundary of the
conservation area although the site is
outside of the Conservation Area
the plan showed the camera to be cited
up to eight meters above ground level
the dimensions are listed which showed
that the main camera would be just over
200 millimeters wide by 350 millimeters
in height it would also project out from
the pole by around 550 millimeters
so this is the pole here which is
subject to the application
and here are some street view photos
there's the pole in the background as
well
so in summary the officer's
recommendation is for approval subject
to conditions there have been a few
updates as listed in the update sheet
and this closes my presentation thank
you Victoria thank you very much does
anyone have any we have again no
speakers so does anyone have any
questions or points for clarifying
no let's move into debate who'd like to
kick us off cancer Jennings was first
there are no objections to the Town
Council award member I don't see a valid
planning reason to go against the
officer's recommendations so I'm happy
to propose it with Grant thank you very
much Council Harvey please can I second
I shall consider it and see if anyone
else wants to First no okay in that case
we have a proposal to Grant secondly by
councilor Harvey uh could I please have
a show of hands please in favor
that is once again unanimous so
committee therefore resolves Grant
application 2203210 ful on Ulster Road
in Stratford New Haven do we have any
urgent business please we do not in that
case thank you very much to everyone
involved
thank you very much to everyone involved
from offices to members of the public
and of course you members as well the
meeting is now closed